What will happen?
The Joe Rogan experience.
How did Sanchez figure out how to do
Moitai different than anybody? Ah, man,
he's so interesting. What is quick
switches of the feet and like,
even the way he throws kicks is yet
Skyler like a little different flavor.
Everything. He don't think he can
help it. You know what I mean?
There's just something about the
guy's character. A just like his,
his fighting is him. Right. You know,
like he's just, he's kind of outgoing,
like just a weird funky guy and it
makes sense that he fights like that.
You know what I mean? It's not like
he's just like seriously stern guy,
but then goes out there
and fights all crazy.
Like he seems like his fighting is
definitely an expression of himself.
He's so good, man. Yeah, he's so good. I,
I like watching him just warm up sneakers
on outside sweat and throwing elbows
and knees and Sherry think he's a bad
motherfucker man. And he's, you know,
he's not young now. I think he's in
his forties is he? Yeah. Really? Yeah.
Can we look, help hold sanitize
38 38 Oh, he's getting there.
It's getting there.
But meanwhile I was in his prime still
find people up all the times a month,
multiple times a month. Have fight. Good
luck. Yeah. Shows this and like dynamite.
It's Instagram was awesome man and he's
got these great videos of him warming up
and you watch him, him, his movement
man. It's like wow, that guy's,
he's something special.
It takes a lot of fucking energy to
move around the way he does too. Yeah,
I'm sure he still shows up to
the gym every single day too.
I'm sure like holding pads for
foreigners and all that stuff.
I stopped by Y'all cow Jim.
He wasn't there but I hear like there is,
I look at that again.
Mother fucking man right there.
He just posted a video the
other day where this crazy wig
go to CP. If I have video of him. There
it is right there. Look at this guy.
Okay.
Even how he throw this cake. It's
different. It's so different. Yeah.
Like he doesn't really like turn all of
his upper body like a lot of the ones
I've seen, right. He's, he's a volume guy,
but he knocks guys out with one shot to
catch it. It, yeah. It just instinctual,
you know, like he didn't even
think about it. Didn't even flinch.
He's so jacked up swipe.
It's interesting when you think of how
many different people are doing it and
that this one guy stands out.
I love outliers man.
So that's one thing that I learned
compared to like watching boy tie in the
states and then going there at the amount
of kicks and knees at their throwing.
Mm. I'm looking at fighting like, okay,
like what does the next
punch going to happen?
These guys throwing kick after
kick after kick for five rounds.
I was like, okay, I'm, I'm definitely not
kicking enough so I got to start kicking.
Mm.
So I,
they like being in Thailand definitely
helped me to learn the importance of KCI.
So we were talking about the shoot
box style Hotville Cordero who is obs?
Absolutely one of the best
striking coaches on the planet.
It's funny that he's such a nice guy
and he trained the most murderous crew.
Angry, Brasilia ambulation.
Pharaoh could not be nicer. Good.
They had Anderson Silva,
they,
ed Vandelay and Vandelay Shogun
digitally look at that photo and, okay,
I'll fail. Show. Good.
Yeah, dude, that's a,
that's a fucking teams have another one.
It's got like Pele. Everybody. Yeah,
that's right. I said pay like too. They
were so the guy who taught more time,
Michael Costa, he was, he was
from that same, that same group.
I really am to this day, do not understand
why more ties. Not more popular.
I've never understood it.